- I just moved here.
So you first moved here a while back,
but what was it like
when you first-
- 1976 I moved here.
- Did you love it?
- I loved it.
Yeah.
- me too.
- I grew up in Philly
and I'd been-
- That's not far.
Yeah, yeah.
- It's not far. It's not far.
I've been here a few times
because my sister lived here,
my sister lived on, on West End Avenue,
so she was very nice to
let me sleep on her couch
for probably, I don't know,
four months until I got my feet.
- That's nice.
- On the ground yeah.
- Yeah. 'Cause it's not a cheap city.
No. It's yeah...
- No, no.
Although I can tell you that in 1976,
my budget for my apartment
was $150 a month.
- So you lived in a closet?
- Right.
Well...
- Of someone else's.
- Of someone else's closet right.
Well, that what, what happened was it was,
I, I had figured that it
was a hundred and fifty,
I don't know where I got the math on that,
but that's what I, that's how
I, that's what I had decided.
- Yeah.
- And so I went into this,
I saw an ad in the back
of "The Village Voice",
and it said, "Artists,
actors, musicians, residents".
And I thought, well,
that's, that sounds good.
It was basically a flop
house. Really, I mean...
(audience laughs)
(Kelly chuckles)
I don't, I guess there were some,
some artists there, but not a lot.
- Like, do you mind living with rats?
- Exactly yeah.
- Yeah.
- Yeah exactly.
- But I walked into the,
into the rental office
and the guy said, "No, we
don't have any single room
apartments, but we do have
a two room apartment".
So basically it was a
kitchen and another room.
And I said, he said, "That's
three and a quarter a month".
And I said, "I can't afford that
and I don't have a roommate".
And he said, "What about this guy?"
I'm sitting on the couch and I, I looked,
"I don't know this guys" and he goes,
"You wanna live together?"
And I was like, "Yeah, okay.
Yeah, okay, we'll live together".
Yeah. And we lived
together for four years.
- Oh my gosh!
- Yeah. In fact,
I just had lunch with him the other day.
- What?
- He was a,
he was a classical pianist.
- Well you were both musicians,
so yeah that's cool.
- Yeah.
He was, he's great, great.
Played beautiful, I
mean, I'd be, you know,
in the middle of the afternoon,
he worked nights at the Copacabana,
and in the middle
of the after-
- This is a TV show.
This is like, yeah what?
(Kelly clasps hands)
- Yeah, yeah.
I'd, he'd come home and he'd be playing,
you know, Chopin or whatever,
and it was, it was, it was really cool.
- That's incred...
I actually moved out to LA
with some random person I did not know.
- Really?
- Yeah.
She just needed a roommate.
I was like, "I'll do it".
I was like, and I moved from
Texas to LA with a stranger.
- Wow.
- Yeah.
- And how long did that last?
- Not long.
We moved into a place and it burned down,
so yeah.
- Uh huh.
- Then I slept in my car for a few days
and then tried out for a
show called "American Idol",
so it all worked out.
(audience cheers)
It all worked out. Yeah.
- What a story.
I mean that's quite a story.
- Life.
Yeah.
- What a story.
- I feel like everyone in this industry
has some crazy thing where
you've either lived in your car
or on a mattress in
someone's house, or yeah,
It's like, yeah, you really
gotta want your dream.
- You do.
- Yeah.
You gotta have
the hunger as well.
- The universe makes you
really want it.